DAN: Hello, everybody.
Thanks for coming today.
I'm Dan.
A few years ago, through a
curious turn of events, I
inherited the job of approving
Andrew's use of the official
Android trademark.
Which means that I get to see
all of his designs before
anybody else.
And so when they asked me to
introduce him, I've got a few
stories, as you might imagine.
But I knew immediately there's
only one story that I could
tell, which is this.
As I'm sure you guys all
remember, if you follow the
little vinyl bug droid figurines
and all, in series
one, one of the designs was
just a green, straight up
green, bug droid.
But in series two, there was one
that was a blue, straight
up blue, bug droid, which
I always thought
was a little odd.
And then in series three,
there was a red one.
I'm like, oh, that's
kind of cool.
And then a few months
ago, I saw the
designs for series four.
And there is this kind of like
orangey, yellowish one on
there, too.
And I'm like, oh my
God, this is an
opportunity not to be missed.
So I pound off this email,
and I'm like, dude.
I'm like, what you need to do
is that orangey gold one
there, you need to make
that Google yellow.
Because then we;ll have all
four of the Google colors.
And if you're a long-term
collector, you can set these
up in Google colors.
I'm like, this is such
a great idea, right?
So a few minutes later,
I get a response.
And he says, yeah, that's
actually your laptop's color
reproduction.
It will be Google yellow.
He's like, I had this
planned all along.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN: And so I became
enlightened.
And so I'd just like to say,
thanks for all your hard work.
Welcome.
And thank you for coming.
ANDREW BELL: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BELL: Hello, everybody.
Thanks for taking time out of
your day to come listen to me
talk and look at some
of my art work.
I'm just going to go through my
art and my career a little
bit, show you some of the work
I've been working on for the
last couple years,
how I got there.
And then we'll move on to some
Android stuff after that.
And then we'll take some
questions at the end.
So let's get started.
Any of you guys in any
art-related department here?
No.
I know there's one small
one in the corner
of the other building.
All right.
That's good.
Hopefully this will all work.
This is the story of how I--
it's kind of dark--
accidentally became a
professional artist.
So this is my childhood.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: That's going to
mess anyone up, right?
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: I was destined to
be something other than a
doctor or a lawyer
from that point.
I had to work out some
serious issues.
This was actually in 19--
probably the very early
'80s in England.
I was born in England.
And being in England, some of
my early influences was this
guy, Postman Pat.
He was one of the early Bob the
Builder style, stop motion
animations.
And then moved on to
Danger Mouse--
awesome cartoon out
of England.
And as I got older, I got
a little cooler, started
skateboarding.
If any of you skateboard, you'd
probably recognize this,
by an artist named Jim Phillips
out of California.
Very iconic.
And then reading comics.
One of my favorite one was
"Bloom County." I didn't
really understand it when I was
reading it, but I loved
the art style, the design.
And then as I got a little bit
older, I got a computed.
I was lucky enough to have a
father who was a bit of an
early adopter.
We had one of the
first CD drives.
It was like this big.
And we had an Apple
2E, Apple 2C.
So I learned Logo basic.
And the first thing I did with
it was try to draw with it.
This is not from the Apple.
This is a little later.
But I got a computer, and
I saw the computer as an
opportunity to be creative, not
just as an opportunity to
do spreadsheets.
So eventually we got a 386sx-16
with 16 color monitor.
And it was amazing.
So I started doing some
ASCII artwork.
I ran a BBS for a while
called Apocalypse.
And you can actually
read that.
It says apocalypse.
Then eventually, I moved up to
all 16 colors and started
incorporating some of the
artwork I grew up on and loved
as a kid into ANSI graphics,
which is just translating
comics and things for bulletin
board system logins.
Are there any BBS nerds?
Anyone old enough?
[LAUGHS]
We've got a couple.
Everyone else is like,
what's happening?
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: And then this is
kind of where I went wrong.
I wasn't destroyed
by a Terminator.
It was more so this.
It was when I saw the computer,
it wasn't just this
little toy to play around on
and make little graphics.
This was a serious tool.
I was kind of blindsided
by this.
No other art mattered anymore.
When I was growing up, I used
to draw and doodle and make
clay sculptures.
And then I saw this--
I can make things
real with this.
This is amazing.
This is the future.
And so when I got old enough to
go to college, I decided to
go to art school.
Oh, I forgot that slide.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: But instead of
picking art school based on
what the best our program would
be or where the best
teachers were, I picked it on
who had the best computers.
I went to a few different
schools, and that's what
really mattered to me.
So I ended up going to the
School of Visual Arts, in
Manhattan, because they had a
lab filled with SGIs, which I
guess is appropriate for
this building, right?
I was like, whoa, these are the
things I've seen on that
one TV special they put out
about CGI before it was
popular or people knew it was.
And I was just blown away.
So I spent years ignoring
the fine art side.
I still had to take drawing
and painting classes.
But I was focused on the
computer as not a
tool, as the tool.
I was kind of one-track
minded.
I did some OK stuff.
This is my thesis project about
killer teddy bears.
[CHUCKLES]
And a bit of an aside--
for the end of the thesis
project, you need to have some
sort of logo graphic
or something.
So in case anyone's wondering
where my company name came
from, my company's Dead Zebra,
Inc. And everyone wonders,
how'd you come up with that?
It was a joke in college, is
how I came up with that.
And it's since been abstracted
a bit to the current logo I
still use today.
So fast forward a few years.
I couldn't find a job in New
York doing 3-D animation.
There wasn't really too
much going on there.
Blue Sky was still working
on "Ice Age" one.
It hadn't come out yet.
I think there was Rhythm &
Hues doing commercials.
But wasn't too much to be had.
And no offense to California,
but I didn't want to come out
to California.
All the 3-D jobs were in LA.
And being in New York for a few
years, I just fell in love
with New York.
And I couldn't see myself
driving everywhere.
So I was lucky enough when I
was in college to get an
internship at Marvel Comics,
which was great.
Just randomly, from my
experience in the past doing
computer graphics and putting
together some crappy little
web pages, someone said, hey,
come work for free for us.
So all right, sounds great.
And eventually that turned
into a little job.
And then eventually that job
turned into another job at
Nickelodeon.
So I was at Nickelodeon
for five years.
And while there, these
guys were born.
This is 2002.
And this is the reason
I am an independent
professional artist.
It's not Apple.
It's not a Mac.
It's because this
computer sucked.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: I'll explain.
So every time this computer that
I worked on-- not this
exact one, but one
very similar--
it would crash several
times a day.
And it would take about 5
to 10 minutes to reboot.
I don't know if it was the
software on there or the
networking or what.
But it was awful, and it
was a waste of time.
So every time it would crash,
I would just grab a little
note card or a Post-it Note
and draw something on the
side, not actively thinking,
oh, I'm getting back into
illustration.
This is great.
Just thinking I need to kill
five minutes and look like I'm
doing something so I
don't get fired.
And they're not very good.
There's like a pickle
with legs.
I don't even know
what that is.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: But I mean, it
happened often enough that
this is my desk after awhile.
You can see, I just started
putting them up on my cubicle
and around up top there.
And after a few months, I had
100 something little monsters
lying around.
And so being as savvy as I am,
I thought, ah, the internet.
I should put them
on the internet.
That's a great idea.
Other people should see me
wasting time, so it's not just
my coworkers.
So using my rudimentary
skills--
this is my first website.
It was built on PHP,
some HTML.
And it was built so crappily
that if I didn't upload a new
drawing every day, the site
would crash completely.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: That was good
motivation for me to practice.
Because it would take my
email down, with it.
I mean, it was that bad.
[LAUGHS]
I really didn't know
what I was doing.
But I ended up keeping up
the schedule for years.
I had to force myself into it
because I was still getting
out of that mindset as the
computer as the tool.
I had go a long way
around there.
So I started put them
up, new drawings.
I Actually, I put out some black
and white screen prints,
just mostly for myself
and my friends.
And then people were going
to the website
on a regular basis.
I had some friends doing web
comics and comic books, and
they shared my link.
Back in the day, there may have
been some web rings, if
anyone remembers those
web rings.
And eventually I
put a t-shirt.
And people bought it-- maybe
like a dozen people.
But to me that was
blowing my mind.
And this little stapled-together
book with
some of my drawings in
black and white.
And over the years,
the drawings got
a little bit better.
The website got a bit better.
It no longer crashed
all the time.
But I did was to keep up my
daily schedule for, I think,
six or seven years straight,
which is kind of crazy now
that I think about it.
I didn't have much of
a life in general.
I took out some ads
in some magazines.
Still doing this all on the
side while I was at work.
Drew some more creatures.
A few more.
Kept going.
And eventually, I had a pretty
good stable full of monsters
to deal with.
So armed with all my monsters
and a book and some new
t-shirt designs, and
a toy-- we'll talk
about those more later--
the next obvious step was to
head to Comic-Con, where I
could really meet the fans one
on one and talk to people and
have a really close
interpersonal relationship
with everyone.
Oh, yeah.
This is Comic-Con.
I'm here, somewhere, I think.
Oh, yeah, here I am.
That's my booth.
All right, luckily, I'd done
some smaller Comic-Cons before
that, so I wasn't totally
blown away.
But here's proof that I can
actually interact with fans at
Comic-Con on one on one basis.
And I got a chance to be
spontaneous, talk to people,
draw on the spot, doodle
for people.
Probably done thousands of
doodles, just people that walk
up to the booth.
And this was 2005, when I said,
all right, I've got
enough people that are buying
some t-shirts and prints from
me, that know about me, that I'm
going to quit my job and
see how it goes for--
I'll give myself six
months to a year.
That was seven years ago,
so still going OK.
I started taking my drawing
over there.
This is an art show at a little
toy store in New York
called Kidrobot.
Has anyone seen that?
This is in their original
store, and so
it was pretty tiny.
So just art among
the merchandise.
But for me, that was
a pretty big step.
And then I got a gallery show.
So my first solo gallery show,
I decided to tackle the tiny,
easy to deal with subject
of everything
between life and death--
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: --in the form of
different chromosomes in the
artwork, and everything in
between that, including
viruses, tumors, parasites.
This is a little sculpture with
eggs and skulls together.
And if anyone's ever been to
New York for an extended
period of time or is in the
art scene, you've probably
been to hundreds of
gallery shows.
I know I have.
And they get boring.
They blend together.
They're just art
on white walls.
And I realized that, and my
artwork is no exception.
So I think one of the best
things to do in that situation
is to try to create an
experience, something that
people will remember.
I think Google's really good at
that, especially with the
Google Doodle team.
So you go to the home
page and there's
something to interact with.
You kind of forget just if
you go to the Google
page, there's a logo.
It's fine.
But if you go there and you
can actually experience
something, you're going
to remember that.
Sometimes it's as simple as
painting a wall and creating
context for your artwork and
products to live in, just
adding some graphics.
Sometimes it's just starting
surrounding the artwork.
And then sometimes it's going
really big and taking over an
entire space.
This is the cafe section of a
gallery space in Paris, just
out of Paris.
A wall-to-ceiling graphics--
can't really avoid it.
And then this is probably
one of my favorite
experiences we created.
This is in a gallery show
in Chicago, a little
store called Rotofuji.
They have a gallery
in the shop.
And the show itself was about
famine and death.
It was called "Love the End."
My relationship was falling
apart at the time.
Really dark, Earth-ending
volcanoes, and oil rig
bursting into flames,
and loneliness.
But in the corner the gallery
over here, we built a pit.
It was about four feet deep and
maybe like five feet wide.
And we filled it with
100 of these guys.
They were called Worribles.
They were designed--
when you hug them they take
all your worries away from
you, make you feel better.
And so the show that
was actually pretty
dark, all the work--
I mean, it's still kind of
playful-- but we had kids
jumping in this pit.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: This one kid in
particular was beating the
hell out of everyone else
that would come near
him with the Worribles.
So since then, if given the
opportunity, I think creating
experience rather than just
throwing your art up is
probably the right way to go.
So I'm just going to go through
some of my-- now I'm
just going to throw some art
up on the screen and
show you some art.
But you're experiencing it.
So, this is some of
my work on paper.
I've tried to go beyond just the
standard black and white
imagery that I was used
to doing some things.
I started out just trimming some
edges, making some paper
look old, adding some detail,
some gold paint here and
there, getting a little more
involved in the shading.
And then after that, I
decided to take it
a little bit further.
You can't really see here--
but I'll zoom in--
this little guy has three
different layers of paper.
So he's got the eyeball in one,
then the main drawing,
then behind it there's
a bit more depth.
I extended that a bit more.
This one has a metal needle
and like four or five
different layers.
It's kind of bright in
here and a lot of
these are kind of dark.
I apologize.
And this one that
includes cotton
stuffing, needles, thread.
You can see some of
the details here.
And I still do the black
and white drawings.
I try to make them a little
more elaborate.
I've added a few more
shades of gray to
spice them up a bit--
not just light gray.
Some cool grays, some warm
grays, some yellowish grays, a
few reds here and there.
And they've gotten a little
more complex sometimes.
This is one from a show
about brothers.
And some people might
have seen this one.
This is the Android brothers
having some delicious apple.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: I don't know
if you can see that.
It's on water-color paper to
give it a little more texture.
And I think I've settled
somewhere in the middle.
It's got the deckled edges.
I gave it a little bit
of gold on the edges.
And then in the middle there of
the head there's a little
gemstone on the paper.
This is recently.
It's kind of where
I am these days.
All right, I want to talk a
bit about prints, or the
Recession Special.
It's helped me survive that
period a few years ago where
everything was pretty rough.
I started a little club where
you could pay a monthly fee
and you'd get a print
every month.
So that was a way people for
to stay engaged with me
without a major commitment, but
know they're going to get
something on a regular basis.
And I prints.
Prints are fun to do, they're
fun to make, and they're a
great way to translate stuff
that is either too expensive,
or too big, or too crazy
to otherwise deal with.
There's a painting I did that's,
I think, about five
feet tall, over eight
feet wide.
Obviously, hard to hang in
your New York apartment.
But prints--
good way to translate it.
This is just a lithograph.
Printing gives you
so many options.
This is a screen print
with many colors.
And the great thing about screen
printing is it gives
you some texture options, too.
We did the main colors in flat,
and the black outlines
were in a high gloss,
contrast black.
So when you see it in person,
it really has a
nice feel in the hand.
And these are letterpress
prints.
And how they make those is
they have these blocks of
metal with the different images
on them, and they stamp
them into the paper.
So when you look at them and
you look at the paper, it's
actually indented in there.
The inks are impressed
in the paper.
So it really gives you a good
physical feel-- very different
from the flat screen
that we're used to.
I still did some
digital stuff.
This is a digital print
of a drawing.
But I decided to do each
one different.
This is the base one.
So each member of the print
club got a different one.
So I'd take the base digital
print and draw on it with
pencil and color it to give
everyone a little different
experience.
I still love digital, because it
lets me do colorful and fun
things quickly and easily.
This is from a recent show,
opened two weeks ago in Vienna
called Odd Obst which
is about fruit.
I like food.
I like food artwork.
This is some cherries.
This is a fun one of toast.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: And this
is probably the most
popular one I've done.
This is called
"Never Look Back." [LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: And it started just
as a digital print in a
show in 2005, but it inspired a
sequel, "Never Look Back 2,"
and a trequal, and beyond
that a toy.
And prints and toys are
something that kind of go
great together.
People don't always have room
for the toys, or they can't
afford the toys.
But usually there's
some wall space.
So if I have a toy coming out, I
like to pair it with a print
as an option for collectors.
So speaking of toys.
And I have "toys" in quotes
here, because I'm sure most of
you are familiar with adult
collectibles that are not toys
for adults.
they're not adult toys.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: They're
toys for adults.
There's a very big difference.
And when people ask me what I
do these days, I have to be
very specific.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: To me, toys that
I put out are sculptures.
They're short run, limited
edition sculptures.
And they might be made of vinyl
or plastic, but they
might as well be bronzed.
That's how I see them.
This whole scene started
probably in the late '90s.
I was working at Nickelodeon
when I first saw this stuff.
I had a co-worker who had one
of these guys on his desk.
I said, hey, what's that toy
or thing on your desk.
And he told me, oh, it's
this toy by this
designer in Hong Kong.
This guy on the left here is
Eric So and the guy on the
right is Michael Lau.
I was like, oh, that's cool.
Where did you get it?
He told me where he got it.
And he was like, yeah,
it was like $120.
What?
You paid $120 for a toy?
You're insane.
So I went down to the store, and
then I think I spent $300
on toys that day.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: I had never
considered that before.
As an artist, I'd never
considered that you could have
something that wasn't a $3,000
metal sculpture or a giant
stone sculpture.
It's somewhere in between
a toy for kids and a
piece of fine art.
A lot of them are limited to
anywhere from 5 to 500.
So I immediately started
working on something.
I started this guy in 2004.
This is my first toy,
named Grub.
And the toys that I'd seen up
until that point, they were
just little statues.
But I wanted to make it a
little more interactive.
So he could swap his faces out
depending on your mood and how
you were feeling that day.
My second toy was
called Zliks.
And it came as a three set.
And I tried to carry some of
that interactivity over.
You could swap their heads out,
swap their eyeballs out.
There were different colors,
and you could
swap between a few.
But this is when it really
clicked to me that I had not
wasted my four years in art
schools learning computer art.
Because, oh, 3-D reprinting
is now a thing.
It was still pretty expensive
and not very accessible when I
started working on this.
But it was when I came
full circle, I think.
I was like, oh, hey, I can use
what I had learned to do
prototyping.
So we did some color mockups.
And here's that guy,
Zliks, another set.
And after that was a guy
called the Giver.
And the idea behind this guy was
that each one would come
with a gift or a present that
he would present to you.
And this is the Giver--
he has the Dumpling of Doom.
This is the Pestilence edition
Giver, Dumpling of Doom.
It's cute.
It's still a little dark.
I think that sort of
sums up my style.
This was the Giver of War.
It's hard to see here, but the
bomb has a big F on it.
So it came with an F bomb.
This one is called the A-Type.
And it was collaboration with a
store in New York called My
Plastic Heart.
It was an extrapolation
of their logo, which
is a plastic heart.
And he was fun because I used my
computer to pre-vis how he
would sit and stand and if he
could hang upside down.
This is a recent one called
Can of Worms.
And this is the one
that just came out
maybe like a week ago.
This is called the Dealmaker.
And he's one of the first
Japanese-style, soft vinyl
productions to be made the US.
Until now, most of it's been
done in Japan, or there's some
Hong Kong versions
of it as well.
But that was made in California,
right here.
And this one is coming
up, so, spoilers.
This is from my company,
Dead Zebra.
And it's about eight
inches tall.
It's the chess piece
style thing.
His mouth opens.
You can put things
inside of it.
And I'm excited about this
because it also comes with a
pair of shoes.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: When I go to do
something, if I'm in my house
and I need like a new hat or a
new table or a new bookshelf,
instead of saying, I'm going
to go to Ikea, I
say, can I make one?
Can I go get one made?
So I've always wanted to
my own kind of shoes.
But I usually wear Onitsuka
Tigers, which is what this is.
So one day I was like, I need
a new pair of shoes.
I should see if I
can hook up with
them and work on something.
And that will be coming
out this summer.
So yeah, working with other
companies is always fun.
Sometimes they have a platform
that they've already designed
that they give to you to see
what you can do with.
This is a Dunny from Kidrobot.
It's been around for awhile.
It's one of the original
popular collectibles.
And sometimes you have
less to work with.
This is pretty basic,
but tried to
translate my art to it.
And then other times, I get to
be in control of the platform,
which is nice.
I think you guys are
familiar with this.
We'll come back to
some Androids.
I've got plenty to show
you in a few minutes.
But this is from series one,
one of the original ones.
And this is more recent,
Sir Knightly Bild.
I still do some sculptures,
actual sculptures, one-off
editions, two or
three editions.
This is called "Heart Attack."
It's a heart just running in a
blood splat.
I'm still obsessed with food.
This was some zombie
candy corn.
I did a series of three
of four of these.
And they came with little
magnets in their feet, so you
could put them on different
stands or
stick them on things.
And then last year, I followed
that up with a "KillKat," evil
wafers, sort of Siamese
twin monsters.
I do some healthy food, too.
Some apples, some evil, apples,
some sad apples.
And some more figurative
stuff.
It's kind of hard to see this
because they're dark.
But this was a small baby
creature in a mouse trap.
It's kind of strange,
I suppose.
Now that I say it out loud, that
sounds kind of horrible.
But even with the sculptures,
I try to make it where it's
something that's still
practical.
This was a wall-hanging unit.
It came with this guy.
But I did another one that
came with nothing, so you
could put your own stuff
inside of it,
if you wanted to.
And this guy, you could take his
head out and put a cone of
incense in his head and
then when lit it up.
And he would smoke
out of his eyes.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: And then somewhere
in between the
sculpture and the toy
is a resin edition.
So you can do a design and then
run 30, 40, 100 of them.
It's not quite toy production,
it's not quite individual hand
production.
But I like to hand finish them,
make each one a little
different, but some
weather on them.
These are called "Glob
in a Box."
And with the resin production,
this is called "The Watcher."
I did this for show.
It's about this big.
It's a pretty good one.
And I took that and I had
a few extras made
of the blank resin.
So it's been transformed into
various things, including this
bat and an octopus with an egg
in his mouth for a show.
This is based off another
artist's character called
Scary Girl.
And this guy turned into this.
So there's sort of a subset of
the toy and collectible world,
do it yourself.
Pretty popular.
Sometimes you get a figure
and you just paint on
it or draw on it.
And other times you get
something that's kind of
already set in what
it looks like.
This is called Misfortune
Cat from [INAUDIBLE].
So I took that guy, I sculpted
on top of him, hollowed out
his belly, added a skull,
and ended up with this.
And then sometimes they give
you some things like this.
It's a station wagon.
They had a show of custom
station wagons, which is a
challenge to me because
I draw monsters.
I don't draw stationed wagons.
So I strapped a giant
monster to the roof.
You might recognize
this guy, Stitch.
So I like reimagine things as
much as possible instead of
just slapping artwork
on something.
So I dismantled poor little
Stitch here and reassembled
him into two characters
called Mile and Ditch.
So that's some of my artwork.
I hope you will join me in
looking at your world a little
differently, maybe deconstruct
some things, maybe approach
your food with caution, or
sympathy, depending on how you
feel that day.
I'm going to show you guys some
Android stuff, if you're
interested.
Anyone?
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BELL: All right, how many
of you guys have Android
collectibles?
[LAUGHS]
That's pretty much everybody.
I guess you wouldn't be
here otherwise, right?
So a few years back, I got the
opportunity to start working
on these guys.
If you'd like to
hear about it.
Some of our early prototype
testing design.
So how it came about is actually
through comics,
strangely enough.
My time a Comic-Con was
also not wasted.
I got to meet an artist at the
small press table doing weird
little comics on the
side who also
happened to be a developer.
And he happened to develop
for a little
company called Danger.
I don't know if you guys have
ever heard of Danger, which
Andy Rubin ran, which later
started Android, and the rest
is history.
But my contact with this guy
was through Comic-Con.
And our subsequent friendship
led to him calling me up one
day and saying, oh, hey, we've
got this project at Google.
Maybe we can do some promotional
stuff for it.
You make toys--
got any ideas?
I said, yeah, I've
got some ideas.
See what we can do.
So I started working on this,
a little mini figure here.
This is some of the
early concepts.
Top one's basically what
we ended up with.
We were trying to figure out
what to do with the legs.
As you know, the Android figure
itself would probably
just topple over if it was
just cylindrical legs.
We tried to maybe make him
short, give him a lower center
of gravity, make him round,
maybe make them triangular.
But the top one felt the most
natural, so we went with that.
These are some of the early
designs from series one.
Some of them kind of
made it through.
If you're familiar with series
one, you can see what they
turned into.
My favorite one on the
top right there was
rejected quite quickly.
This was my design.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: I thought
it was awesome.
But someone in the Google legal
department had other
issues with it.
I don't know why.
I think it should
still be made.
So yeah, series one, it was
mostly designed by myself.
And it was originally just
going to be an internal
promotional giveaway situation,
some goodies.
But I said, hey, you
know what, there's
this whole toy world.
People might be into this.
People might be interested
in this.
Can I make a few more and
maybe sell them to them?
And they said, well, whatever.
[LAUGHS]
All right, there was some
legal stuff in there.
But theoretically, that's
what I heard.
Whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: Do what you want.
It's fine.
So we made a few more.
And I had no idea--
it's a toy based on a brand new
mobile operating system
that has a mascot.
I thought either I was going to
be stuck with a truckload
of little green figures or
it would do really well.
And thankfully, it has done
really well and Android is
still around.
These are some of the
early designs.
This is CopperBot.
He had a metal finish.
But the original designs were
all relatively simple,
straightforward.
Series two-- after
that, we got a
few more people involved.
We did some other materials.
So this is Greeneon.
He was a harder plastic.
But he was clear, so you
could put stuff in him.
And you guys have probably
seen this guy, Noogler.
He was the first Android mini
with an accessory slash
different head, the
working beanie.
And this was designed
by a fellow
Googler called Jeff Yaksick.
He was on the Android team.
And this one by Gary
Ham called Cupcake.
He actually smells
like a cupcake.
So we're experimenting with
stuff like that as well.
And series three, we
continued that.
I invited a few more artists to
work on different series.
And we changed the arm design
from a standard little peg to
a round ball and cup design,
which gives it a little more
freedom, a little
more expression.
This is by my friend
Kelly Denato.
She's done some great artwork.
It's called Pandroid,
with the pan flute.
And my friend Sket, the
8 Ball Hustler.
I think this was the first
one with a hat--
not the last.
And then this was one
from series three.
They all came with a little
mini one inside.
And one this was a favorite
from series three by Matt.
It came with a little ball.
So you could pull his head off
and put the ball in and shake
it like a real spray can.
And beyond the artist series,
we do quite a few for Google
internal departments
and promotions.
This is for analytics.
I think the analysts ones,
they're really simple, but
they're some of my
favorite designs.
This is the first one.
And then, of course, they
upgraded their interface, so
this is a more recent one.
And this one has proven
to be very popular.
They gave it away at
South by Southwest.
It's really simple.
It's really basic.
But people just really
love it.
It's Schemer from the
Schemer Project.
This is for the mobile
ad unit--
Mobley the Ad Man.
Came with a little fedora and
a little Nexus phone.
And this, I've just been
informed, you can only win if
you do good work
on the UX team.
[LAUGHS]
A lot of the other ones are
given away at events or for
departmental things.
But this one seems allusive.
Anyone go into I/O?
Well, you might be get
one of these guys.
This is the I/O Tester.
He's a cross between a crash
test dummy and a developer.
Oh, they're the same
thing, right?
So he comes with little
safety goggles and a
fade in the I/O colors.
Hopefully it'll be enough
to go around.
And if we've got some
coming here, too.
Aw!
What's up next Android minis?
I brought some samples.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: So people really
like the clear ones.
They like they can take
their heads off.
They like they can put
stuff inside of them.
And so this is the next
set coming out.
It's called the rainbow
series.
And it comes in this awesome
box, which is
also a display case.
It flips open.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BELL: And [INAUDIBLE].
It's got one sparkly.
It's got sparkles.
We haven't embedded sparkles
in one before,
so that was a first.
And then, coming up later this
year, is series four.
It'll be coming out probably
late summer, early fall.
Looking at August, September
probably.
And now I believe I'm going
to get grilled with some
questions from the audience
and from online.
AUDIENCE: All right, let's
give it up for Andrew.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Say your name
and your question.
AUDIENCE: My name is Alex.
I worked here at Google.
And I'm a big fan
of your toys.
And one thing I discovered when
I bought one on eBay was
that it was a knockoff.
And I was wondering, how do you
guys approach knockoffs?
How do you prevent them
from happening?
And what's your take on that?
ANDREW BELL: It's hard.
In some cases, it's
impossible.
AUDIENCE: Just don't buy them.
ANDREW BELL: What's that?
Just don't by them?
Well, that's was part of it.
I mean, people do buy them.
Series one came out and was
popular, and series two came
out and was popular.
And naturally, some factories
saw that and were like, hey,
let's just make some of those.
So pretty soon there were some
really crappy copies out on
the market.
One way we helped prevent it is
I had to switch factories.
That factory you saw in the
video was a brand new factory,
a brand new building we had.
Because series two, there were
some extras, some dubious
quality ones that were slipping
out the back door
from the factory that I was
contracted to earlier.
Now I have a tightly controlled
supply chain where
it's just me and the guy
that runs the factory.
And we keep the designs down.
And then there's the occasional
cease and desist.
And people in Hong Kong and
China tend to ignore those.
Or light fires with them.
Luckily, I have a representative
over there who
tries to stay on top of that.
But I think the best way to
combat it is to make better,
higher quality, and
keep innovating.
Like series three, we added
the ball joint arms.
I haven't seen anyone
copy that.
It's too expensive,
not worth it.
The paint quality we have on the
newer ones, you can't copy
it for the price that they
want for the fake ones.
So that's probably best way,
is just to outdo them.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Bringing in other
artists-- how did that start?
Was it just like, hey,
I'm running up ideas.
Can someone help me out?
Or were you working with some
other artists that you thought
could contribute?
ANDREW BELL: Well, the whole
collectible scene, the toy
scene, is based off of that--
different artists working on
different platforms and
working together.
So while series one was mostly
me, just proof of concept,
series two, I wanted to get
some people from Google
involved, use some
of their designs.
And then series three was more
getting other artists that I
know and other friends
that I have.
And it's finding people whose
artwork and style would work
well with the Android
figure itself.
Not everyone can design
for a limited palette
or a limited size.
AUDIENCE: This one from Mike
L. in Louisville, Kentucky.
So there's Cupcake--
why were there no other
designs [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW BELL: After that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW BELL: There are plans.
It has been discussed
over the years--
you keep making fun version
names, and we'll
keep working on plans.
So hopefully in the next couple
years we'll see something.
AUDIENCE: When you first decided
you wanted to start
making toys, were you working
with somebody else who had
already made them, or did you
figure out the process?
Because that looked
really involved.
I didn't realize how
involved it was.
ANDREW BELL: Yeah, it took
awhile to learn.
My first idea was just, I'm
going to make a toy.
I didn't let myself get
discouraged when I realize how
impossible that was.
I was going to toy conventions--
there's the toy
fair every year that's
been going on for
years in New York--
going to toy stores--
the guy who runs the shop in New
York that has those toys
that I first saw-- say, hey,
where do you get your stuff?
Who makes these things?
And eventually, I managed to
find some connections to some
people that were more familiar
with the process.
And they helped me through
the first one.
And then after, tried to do most
of it myself after that.
And now, having been at the
factory and intimately
familiar the process, it makes
it easier to design toys
knowing the technical
limitations and how things
actually get made.
It was research, talking
to people, schmoozing.
I'm not good at it, but I was
persistent, so it worked.
AUDIENCE: All right, our next
question from the Dori and the
public forums was from JF
Isla, in Riverside.
Will you ever consider letting
fans submit designs for one of
your series, because I have
a couple in mind?
Wink, wink.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW BELL: A lot of people
have a lot of good ideas.
I don't know.
Fan sourcing is difficult.
Because a lot of times you get
a lot of things like Pokemon
or Ultraman.
There's some really cute
designs, some really stuff.
But a lot of it's not as fun
and creative as it could be
and could never get made
for copyright reasons.
But I think it'd be fun to have
a contest where we do
some fan stuff.
I'd certainly like to get more
Google people involved in
future series.
Maybe we'll have an internal
company contest.
AUDIENCE: Get working.
ANDREW BELL: Get some of those
creative minds going.
AUDIENCE: We've got
some artists here.
ANDREW BELL: Yeah.
Yeah, I think that
would be fun.
AUDIENCE: A bunch of people on
the public G+ are asking if,
not the whole presentation,
because it kind of shows the
new design, but the beginning
of the presentation is going
to be put online so they can--
on the public G+?
ANDREW BELL: Yeah, I think most
the stuff up until the
secret stuff, we'll
have it up there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: All right, this one
is from our Googler Matt.
Do you have any fun stories
behind any of
your Android designs?
ANDREW BELL: Not too funny.
Not the ones I can talk
about, at least.
Some of the fun ones are the
ones that get canned, like the
Blue Screen of Death one.
But nothing too crazy.
AUDIENCE: So the next question
is from myself.
Did you think it would sell
beyond series one when you
[INAUDIBLE]?
I think partially answered
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BELL: Yeah, I don't think
anyone here or myself
knew if people would want a
phone mascot as a collectible
or to spend money on something
that is essentially a
marketing tool, when
you think about it.
But yeah, I had no idea it would
as popular, as big, or
go on as long as it has.
I'm happy for it.
And I'd like to keep doing it.
AUDIENCE: All right, another
question, from Yani G. And I'm
sorry, I'm only going to go
there, Yani, if you're here.
There's been some frustration
from the collector's community
recently about the recent
designs being very similar to
each other, all differing by the
lettering or the scrolls.
What is your take on this?
ANDREW BELL: He's referring
to one specific.
He's referring to the Chinese
Near Year edition, where it
came with a little scroll.
Each one had a different printed
saying on it, seven
different ones so you didn't
know which one you would get.
I think it's just part
of collecting.
In one way, from a technical
financial standpoint, you need
to make variations of things
to keep the cost of the
crazier ones down.
Now, for every plain blue are
plain green Android, I can
make that crazy one that
had 100 prints on it.
Because it averages it out.
But I understand this can be
frustrating for completists to
find something, or when things
are similar to each other.
But I think it's part
of the game.
AUDIENCE: This one
is from external.
Jonathan, from Brooklyn.
I think you answered it.
Would you consider doing a
five inch or eight inch?
ANDREW BELL: Yeah, definitely.
Yes.
Yes, I would consider it.
I think that ones more
about 10 inches.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Also, a part of this
question is, do you also to do
a DIY, do-it-yourself,
Android?
ANDREW BELL: Yeah, have plans
for a do-it-yourself large
version, too.
So I expect to see some pretty
crazy electronic versions of
that, because there's more room
to fit more Servos and
things inside.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW BELL: Well, we're
starting with the green and
the outline.
And then hopefully we'll be able
to maybe translate some
of the existing designs onto
the bigger platform.
Printing gets harder
at that scale.
Printing's actually easier
the small you get.
So we'll see.
Maybe some of the
simpler ones.
AUDIENCE: Makes sense.
All right, just a few
more questions here.
From Alex A., here at Google--
how hard is it to narrow down
which designs you end up using
for each series?
ANDREW BELL: As you saw on that
whole chart of the series
three ones, it's tough
to decide.
Sometimes I decide through those
criteria of copyright
possibility, technical things.
And then other times, it's
just a gut feeling, like
what's going to work
well with other
designs that I've gotten.
Or has this artist
had like three
designs in the last series?
So there's no real formula, just
how it feels and how it
feels in context.
AUDIENCE: I think this has also
been answered from Alex.
The [INAUDIBLE]
bigger things for the
future Androids.
And I think you showed us what.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So he's thinking
ahead, obviously.
ANDREW BELL: We're always
working on stuff.
AUDIENCE: Good questions,
though.
Good questions.
So do you know it takes three
to six months for a single
project to come alive, these
figurines, from the design
phase, and he goes, working
with manufacturing and
everything.
And he works with multiple
projects at the same time.
I contacted him back in January
of this year and said,
hey, Andrew.
Do you want to come
and have a talk?
A bunch of people would
love to have you.
Without hesitation, he said,
yes, I'll do it.
So I applaud his loyalty
and commitment.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BELL: He promised
me free lunch.
That's why I showed up.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You could
come every month.
Andrew is a pretty big fan of,
obviously, art and everything.
And he also appreciates
our doodle.
I've seen him treating nice
doodles and what we create.
So we got something really
simple from our Doodle team.
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BELL: Oh, awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you could open
it up if you would like.
ANDREW BELL: I'm not
going to wait.
I was never good at that.
Oh, that's awesome.
AUDIENCE: So this is an artist's
proof from our
Doodler [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BELL: Oh, cool.
That's great.
Done in the Haring style.
That's awesome.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: You're welcome.
We hope you like it.
[APPLAUSE]